[Music]
testing
turkey delivery hope you're hungry
anita are we expecting a turkey i hope
not you certainly don't need a second
one
i'm not seeing a turkey on your schedule
sir
so we live in the building and we
thought it would be a good community
builder if every week we made a turkey
and brought it to a neighbor so should
we just uh leave it here or should we
are you yes that's right cbs nine
seasons wow oh
gee
oh
come in
okay uh full disclosure this is actually
the first time we've done this and now
we know how weird it is that we didn't
bring some yams that's true
you're the guy doing the podcast
i am
look i'm sorry how i was with your dog
i was having a rough day
yeah
uh we heard you knew tim cono was he a
good guy
i didn't know him personally
he used to work for me
i fired him
you fired him why did you do that sting
that's personal
sting
i know that you know that i know what
it's like to be famous strangers think
they have a right to know our business
but they never know the real us and it's
isolating it can make us
act poorly
i feel i'm too close to sting
so on top of that sting
um this punk
tim cono lost all your money it might
just make you snap you know might
make you even
murderous what are you all getting at
you think tim's death is my fault
[Music]
well you're right
[Music]
i killed him
sir
no anita i need to release this
i've been so full of rage lately
the day before tim's death i i screamed
at him
you [ __ ] me over you're fired you
should kill yourself
but then he did
and that's why you poisoned my dog
wait i'm sorry what did you say
okay i can't believe i even have to say
this but sting is not a murderer or a
dog poisoner so you think tim was
murdered
i know he was oh my god
what a relief
i've been wrecked with guilt i thought
he killed himself because of me
and you know that that's why we've moved
the tour up that's why we're gutting
this apartment and the building is just
seeped in in guilt and regret
let's give me an idea for a song
i thought it was me
and i was so low
but my words didn't put a bullet into
tim corner oh
oh no
[Music]
i don't think it's gonna make your best
of album well
uh okay
it's hard writing songs okay thank you
for the turkey please
stay away from sting
[Music]